i saw stephen colbert the other night
was doing a trump bit
i'm like really you just oh yeah you
need to google that
yeah did they come up with like a list
of names for him names for him i'm
thinking was this
taped like six months ago right but no
it was like something very recent
yeah it was awful so a month ago they
did the nicknames thing
colbert asked viewers for newt knew he
paused this
music colbert asked viewers for new
nicknames for trump and they didn't
disappoint
on april april they totally did i'm
sorry it's so bad
on april 17th
isn't he a comedian shouldn't he be
coming up with like new stuff
well that's novel wow yes what were some
of the nip nicknames
i don't know what what do you got here
let's see he who shall not be named
eric's dad is that it i don't know they
don't well can i tell you that gutfeld
is actually doing much better in the
ratings than any of those hosts
that's surprising what does that tell
you he's funny yeah
or they're just sick of the old same old
thing i mean
you turn on any one of the hosts you get
the same joke yeah i went on twitter and
i looked at like uh stephen colbert
actually yesterday and then i was like
you may also like
samantha b uh what other all these like
the same
jimmy kimmel uh oh i can't even think i
don't even wanna well
jimmy kimmel had on michael and dell i
thought that was pretty good actually i
i don't know
if it's just like and i ain't saying the
liberal media but the liberal economic
order the liberal international order
was created in 1946 that's a real
organization
though well the word liberal this whole
idea of like these people being fed this
information to promote american
imperialism
i think those people are whether they
realize it or not part of it
no i agree with that i think the reason
why
all of these late-night hosts were in
lockstep is that donald trump was a
rogue
he was not in line with what the the the
administrations of
uh of the past wanted it's funny when
you look at
a lot of the wartime policies of many of
the past presidents and it was expansion
expansion expansion middle east
expansion
and then trump was just roguelike no
we're getting out i don't want to do it
he didn't support him they loved him
when he bombed syria and so what happens
is all of the mainstream late-night
hosts
are in unison trump is bad there you go
i so i don't know about a liberal
liberal economic order but it was
let's get rid of this guy i think the
problem now is
a lot of these these people like like
like colbert
they were they were riding the ratings
wave ragging on trump was just
making them money and it was working and
now trump's gone do you think that they
if they could would they bring him back
just to make money
so i was i was i actually went on brian
kilmeade's uh show when he
i don't know if it's a show but he's
hosting prime time and he asked me if
trump
started his own social network do you
think they would try and get him banned
and i said
i don't know but i kind of lean towards
no
they want trump on social media so they
can talk about them to get ratings
now trump ended up launching just a
website which is not a big social media
platform so i don't think anyone really
cares
what's interesting is that trump emails
me like five times a day
he loves you i mean i got he emailed me
he's like tim take a look at this this
photo of me golfing it's the best
no no but but he emails everybody on
this list and like i got an email and he
said he was golfing and i'm like
i don't care that you're golfing
apparently nobody else did either
they try to write these stories but
trump isn't the president anymore
so they might as well be writing some
guy did something yeah
who cares i like how hollywood is kind
of eating its own though
i'm enjoying that yes the fact that they
canceled the
golden whatever it's called golden
globes golden globes yes
they canceled it yeah it's not going to
happen next year
and ellen degeneres is gone oh
she likes her shows canceled yes wow
she's out
did she retire well that's what she says
she says it's just not challenging
anymore but we all know why
it's because all the stories were coming
out how she was not a nice person
yeah yep yeah people are saying that she
lied about being invited to dakota
johnson's birthday or something and i'm
like
i gotta be honest i really don't care i
know but let's just turn the show off
you know
yeah the centralized hollywood system is
is cracking and falling apart i'm good
with that though yeah i used to like the
oscars way back when i would you know
i would stay up i would watch them i
thought it was funny
and now i could care less yeah the
golden globes are gone
they're gone they got they got canceled
they say uh
it was hardly a far far foregone
conclusion
the controversy has been mounting for
months the la times ex
exposes in february highlighted the
association's insular culture
and open letter and stuff yeah welcome
stuff yeah
good if the oscars are going to go they
didn't do well this year
the oscars yeah it was like 58 down
but has anybody seen any of those movies
i don't even know what they were talking
about right
no but they're doing this diversity
initiative where it's like
we could we could bring out you the
actors you know and love who are in the
movies you know and love
or or hear me out obscure films
by non-white actors ah now i got no
issue
if they want to uh if you know if they
want to give awards to people who aren't
white i don't see it as being an issue
in any capacity
the problem is when they start
they make something that doesn't that
isn't recognizable to anybody in the
country
pulling up movies that no one's seen or
heard of
i don't know who's going to want to
watch that and i'm not saying to be
disrespectful i'm not saying it like
these people should watch it
what i mean is if you've never heard of
it why would you be interested in it now
if they had seen the movie earlier in
the year they might want to see if it'll
win the award
but then i guess people were shocked
that um who was supposed to win
uh chadwick boseman i guess yeah was it
was it him like that
yes and then they ended up giving it to
somebody who wasn't even there uh
anthony hopkins yeah he wasn't even
there
it's just a disaster they i think i i
think it's fair to say get
go broke they've they've put so much in
the basket of
prioritized wokeness and activism that
the product is missing
you know i can't look at robert de niro
anymore because of his support for
andrew cuomo
and billy crystal oh it's sad to me
i i i miss seeing actors that don't tell
me who
they voted for right isn't it weird
though that
actors who probably would never have
thought twice about you are now probably
sitting around their friends saying that
you know oh you
you you fox news employees are evil
fascists or something and it's like
it's just weird to me to have watched
mark ruffalo and all these movies
for a decade it's hard go back to the
avengers before any of this insanity
and i'm like really cool hulk great mark
ruffalo and chris evans
then they start screaming on twitter and
i'm like what is wrong with these people
want to change the world just talk a lot
get involved in politics i did get into
a little bit of a fight with ben stiller
oh really yes on twitter because he was
supporting andrew cuomo and of course
this is going through this
the whole time where i've been a bit of
an advocate on behalf of my husband's
parents and
they were doing some event for
raising money it was ben steller whoopi
goldberg
billy crystal de niro and they were
doing this
online thing where you could meet the
governor through
zoom and you had to pay like a thousand
dollars that goes to his re-election
campaign
so i went on twitter and i was like
whoopi goldberg
ben stiller uh billy crystal did you
know that
governor cuomo put over 9 000 covet
positive patients in nursing homes
you know i i did it because that's what
people need to know about and ben
stiller
came back at me and was like oh miss
little miss sunshine just because you
don't like him doesn't mean you know i
like him and he said something about
trump he assumed that i was a trump
supporter
so i went back and was like well i just
want to let you know that you know my
husband's parents died in
you know in nursing homes and i feel
that he was partly responsible and you
should know about this before you start
raising money
uh on behalf of you know dead
new yorkers uh because of covid and
he i guess did some research wow really
and afterwards
you know went back and said i'm really
sorry for your loss i lost my
dad earlier this year i didn't know your
story
um i'm going to delete my tweet wow i'm
a i'm a fan of ben stiller you know what
me too
i have been since the ben stiller show
in the late 80s good for him
any artwork anyway even even if he came
back and was like i
you know i i'm sorry to hear that but i
disagree and i like cuomo i would have
respected that as well
absolutely and you know at the beginning
it was a it was a gut reaction
you know like you're a trump supporter
um and then
doing a bit of research realizing what
my family has been through he had
empathy and for that
i mean i'm grateful yeah uh in in your
work
are you overtly political not at all
i've never been a political person yeah
ever i always say the red and blue that
i see on a map
are areas of high pressure and low
pressure yes
yeah i mean it's like awesome that's how
insanely tribal it is
that someone tweeted you hey this you
know this bad thing happened
and the immediate assumption is that the
you know meteorologists from fox and
friends
is clearly politically aligned and yeah
i hate being in this position but you
know i feel like if i'm not going to
talk about it
who is going to talk about it you know
well the crazy thing is
they demand it's just i tweeted
criticism of biden
you know i said something like i guess
build back better means crumbling
infrastructure a crippled economy
and escalating middle eastern conflict
and then i get all of it
clearly it gets a ton of retweets
because conservatives are like yeah
biden sucks
and then i get a bunch of liberals being
like yeah well donald trump and i'm like
yes
yes and donald trump continue now biden
right
no it's the craziest thing that if i
criticize biden right now the responses
but trump oh yeah same with the cuomo
thing too every time i go on there but
trump
i don't see you blaming trump well you
know what trump didn't put covet
positive patience into nursing homes
trump is trump uh trump needs to take
responsibility for different things
he trusted too many bad people in a lot
of different ways
we mentioned john bolton being a bad
choice especially for his agenda
trump trusted bad people bad things
happened it's not the same thing as what
biden is doing
by all means if you want to criticize
trump i'm like yes donald trump fired 59
tomahawk missiles into syria we're very
upset about it
now as for joe biden because he's the
president today
the problem is you know you go back to
the trump administration and i try to be
fair
i supported i supported trump in in
november i said here's his agenda items
that i thought were really good school
choice was big i thought that was
fantastic
he was talking about ending the middle
eastern wars and he'd actually making
moves to do it
and i was pretty happy among other
things banning critical race there and
stuff
i said okay i'll vote for the guy i have
no problem saying that but i was also
critical of him
in a variety of ways one he ordered a
commando raid that killed an
eight-year-old american girl and i
believe it was yemen
59 tomahawk missiles mass spending
throughout the throughout the uh the
four years of trump
you have a media that's lying over and
over again about russia and other
ridiculous nonsense
so if i'm going to be accurate i'm going
to be defending trump whether it's about
policy or otherwise i have to be like
that's not true
but when trump did something wrong i'd
say yeah well i don't like that trump
did this and boy was it stupid to hire
bolton that was like the worst thing i
think he could have done
now what's happening is biden is
president
they're not they're not reciprocating in
terms of fairness
biden needs to be heavily criticized but
these people who claim
you know a lot of these leftists who are
socialists want to claim that they don't
actually like biden
they they jump to attention the moment
someone criticizes the guy it's the
stupidest thing ever
come on we're in the middle of of a very
high inflation people are getting scared
and the media you know yelling comes out
there's there's no inflation problem
then a week later the new york times
well inflation's a problem here's what
we've got to do about it
joe biden then says we're going to keep
printing unemployment checks which
chamber of commerce says is contributing
to the unemployment problem
and then they're gone defending joe
biden who's not
a leftist who's not a socialist and i'm
like why are you protecting this guy
again i thought you didn't like him but
he was better than trump
now you're actually standing up for the
guy let's be reasonable
the buck stops the current president you
want to blame trump for covet
my response was we don't have a control
group by which to judge the metrics you
know of
of trump's responses but i think certain
certainly if you think trump didn't do a
good enough job i'm willing to hear your
criticisms
okay now joe biden is president you want
to talk about what's going on well he's
the president so the buck stops with him
nah they never play that game it's
always you know the economy was doing
really well under trump what did they
say
actually this is obama's recovery
efforts and trump's just writing now the
economy is doing miserable well donald
trump
every single time that's exactly how it
goes i love reasonable people
yes they're rare nobody's perfect
i don't i don't know i think the system
itself is really faulty and here i am
enjoying this delicious citrus surge
aoc says it's racist you guys are
surging together right yeah yeah what's
going on over there
i'm kidding aoc didn't say that surge
citrus flavored soda was racist
she said the words that's right that's
right i was like wait sir are they a
sponsor no
no no no we are not sponsored by surge
okay
i just i like having obscure uh
things i love that i mean the fact that
you brought up rc cola
yes i hadn't heard i had not heard that
name in a long time so when people are
downstairs like anything to drink you
want a surge or an rc
people are like you gotta tap really you
have those
but that's exciting you brought
excitement back into my life
i wonder what other like weird 70s 80s
and 90s products did you have a slushie
while you were down there
i heard about the slushies slushies are
good but yeah it was time got a slushie
machine it's gotta be close
okay yeah yeah figured out i was gonna
make an apple berry the next time it's
working
i'd like to be invited yes oh yeah yes
well you can come by anytime
we'll get the slushy machines going heck
yeah bring the family the kids will love
it
anyway i love it jokingly uh we do have
search
it's you know because i think it's
hilarious but uh you know
aoc when when she said that serge was
racist
it's a perfect example of in-name
tribalism
i don't want to rehash an old story i
was just mentioning we had the sodas and
it kind of plays into it but she
recently was talking about israel in
gaza
and then somehow said we don't want to
recognize the plight of palestine
because it would make us
have to recognize the plight of the the
migrants on our own border
what and everyone was like what you know
i think it might be because she doesn't
really have policy positions
maybe it's just cliche or stereotypical
for me to be like ah you know aoc
doesn't have anything going on
but i really do feel like you know in
this culture war and this political
divide
i mentioned in a moment ago the
uninitiated and the initiated there are
people who are just democrats
so the democrats must win no matter what
you can criticize
cuomo for doing something horrible but
their democrat and team democrat must be
protected at all costs
sad you must be team trump it's like
okay i mean look i voted for the guy but
i don't care if you smack talk the guy
if someone comes to me and says yeah
well trump did this that and this i'd be
like damn
that's awful wow yeah well biden you
know
as well as he's the president now so so
let me write down all the bad things
about trump i agree
you're right and uh now let's talk about
biden right they don't want to do it
because this is the the nature of
politics just what team are you
what which team are you on of course fox
news is
is team orange well you're wearing this
edge
that's too red and blue areas of low
pressure high pressure
it is it is fascinating the whole
network is like
well actually you know it's interesting
that there's one network basically
i guess there's there's on news max but
in terms of you know large viewership
all of the other outlets walk in
lockstep fox news is the only outlet
that actually has conflicting
narratives or opinions well and that was
the brilliance of when
it was invented it was because there
wasn't anything out there to represent
the views of the viewers right i mean
there was the cnn but you know cnn back
then was different
it's not the cnn that it is today it's
very boring yeah i was like c-span kind
of
i always got them mixed up when i was a
kid like they both just have video of
congress just talking
is that what they did back in the day
seemed like in the 80s that's what cnn
was
i mean they had people on the ground and
stuff
but it was very boring msnbc is doing
better than cnn which is quite
incredible really is that is that not
the case historically
no i i i mean for many years cnn was
the oh yeah most valuable whatever it
was called
the most trusted name in news i guess
and then uh
msnbc was always the third but now more
than ever they're
they're being you know you've got but
you've got somebody like a rachel maddow
who is nuts stressed
i watched her last night she was the one
saying about the masks that she couldn't
she couldn't bear to get rid of the mask
yeah she's like i have to rewire my
brain to not see people how to mask as a
threat
i saw that and i was like i've never
viewed someone with or without a mask as
a threat
i just mind my own business i go to the
store i buy the cat food and i come back
and we give the food to the cat i don't
know what you're talking about lady
it freaks me out that people think the
way she does yeah and they watch her
show so clearly they do
that's it's really it's really scary
because if people start to
be afraid of each other that's the
ground up totalitarian mentality
because then it's very easy to
manipulate people to do things to each
other to your neighbor turn your
neighbor in like in the soviet you know
gulags two out of five people were
informants and then you have a chris
cuomo who doesn't want to wear a mask
ever but tells people they need to wear
a mask or who fakes being in quarantine
fake quarantine yep
wow i loved it when ben smith of the new
york times actually
called out cuomo and nothing happens of
it you know what
very recently on social media um someone
called him out on it
and they referenced a fox news article
talking about the fake quarantine
and he was like oh well you shouldn't
believe fox news
i went underneath and brought that
article up by ben smith and said hmm
this is not fox news right and there's
actual proof of a guy that saw you
in the hamptons not quarantining thanks
for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time